i just want to talk
initially about ukraine and it feels
like always in war you see women and
girls
being the victims yeah we spoke to the
ukrainian deputy prime minister on the
program last week and she was saying
she'd heard horrible stories about women
being raped for hours and they're
murdered so how concerned are you about
what's happening to women and girls in
ukraine i'm very much concerned i think
we all ultimately always think that war
is about guns and bombs but ultimately
it's about women's bodies so we are
hearing um
stories of human trafficking on on on
the borders but ultimately i think rape
in war is a horrific thing and something
that we need to be aware of you
mentioned there about um trafficking sex
trafficking on the borders in poland
what kind of things are you hearing and
how worried are you about what's
happening um you know what the whole
thing is that the patriarchy and those
that want to be able to pry on women and
vulnerable children where we will always
do it to during
a traumatic incident such as this a lot
of the stuff is antidote at the moment
but they're about but there are stories
of girls going missing and this is the
thing it's like it's it's it's it's a
loss it's a large-scale
move of people and traffickers and those
that want to exploit young people are
going to be there and of course these
are people who are at their most
vulnerable they just fled a war zone 100
and just looking for safety and i think
it's easy for women and girls to be
taken in by traffickers i think we i
think there's there's a broader
conversation that we need to have about
the sex industry and actually how women
and girls are lured into that kind of
conversations because across europe
there's not the conversation that we
need to be having which is about ending
demand and actually really really
looking at the sex industry as a part of
the valentine's women and girls kind of
framework as opposed to some kind of
business essentially so the uk is
obviously preparing for ukrainian
refugees to start coming here through
the friends and family scheme through
the homes for ukraine scheme
how much support do you think needs to
be in place for
women and girls who have obviously been
through this traumatic experience but
also may be very vulnerable themselves i
think we have to take a closer look and
i think the government is going to
do everything it can in order to be able
to support and women and girls but i
think coming back to the question about
um human trafficking and the feeding
into the second the sex industry i think
that's something that we have to be
aware of and it's not a conversation
that is
readily had in the uk within the kind of
broader mainstream media i think we kind
of um
sensationalize it as something that like
you know out of a choice or a job i do
think actually that there is a massive
problem and we will see that
through the sex industry and that abuse
that women fall into as a result of that
so is that something you're actively
pushing in your advisory role then
looking at the sex industry here well
it's something that i was
very much keen on talking about when we
did the consultation the fact that i
don't actually think that prostitution
is a choice i don't actually see as
employment i see it as a form of
violence against women and girls and
some people think that it's a relic
view to have but i think that's a view
that a lot of young women are having at
the moment so i would be i would welcome
us specifically within the home office
or anywhere else within the criminal
justice system we're really looking at
the sex industry um as a form of harm to
women and girls and talking again about
the um ukrainian women
how much of a concern is it for you and
that you know we are getting this um
influx of refugees who are at their most
vulnerable into people's homes is there
a safeguarding issue there there is
definitely a safeguarding issue i don't
think we're necessarily doing as much as
that we would have done for um syrian or
afghan refugees because there's this
kind of idea the fact that because
they're europeans and they'll be a lot
safer in terms of mixing with westerners
um and i just need to i think within
that kind of con and when that kind of
concept is again we've seen um again and
again that those that want to take
advantage of vulnerable people will use
this opportunity where people are
looking for safety in order to abuse
them so i think we have to be wary
unconscious of the fact that there are
going to be some people who don't
necessarily have the best intentions
when they talk about taking refugees in
there's a speed issue isn't there like
getting people here quickly getting them
into housing quickly but also doing the
necessary checks are you worried that
the checks might fall
by the wayside slightly i think because
we're having these conversations i think
that checks will happen but because it's
the kind of the um less rigid
nature of the refugee scheme so when
people are coming in from overseas in
like you know whether it's the iraqis
the afghanistan or somali such as myself
i think there was a lot more um scrutiny
and i think there were there
was a lot more safeguarding that was in
there because we understood that a lot
of these people couldn't speak the
language and would find it hard to
integrate and mix so i think we need to
be wary and not be too flippant about
the fact that just because they're
european and refugees that they're not
going to be as vulnerable as any other
refugees essentially you talk though
about your own background yeah and you
came to the uk as a refugee didn't you i
did at the age of seven and i said that
before that i think london has a very
special place in the world where the
fact that there are a lot of people that
are very much conscious of what the
ukrainians are going through be that the
somalilanders myself and the syrians the
sudanese so there's a lot of people who
actually understand the realities of war
which is quite horrific
what i know everyone's different aren't
they but you know there's a
seven-year-old refugee coming here yeah
what kind of thing do you think
seven-year-old ukrainian girls are gonna
be thinking if they are arriving in the
uk i think that space of just like being
home so one of the things i was lucky
about was i lived in the uk prior to me
coming back so i think that sense of um
just peace and safety and you really
can't put a price on the ability of
actually to be able to sleep at night
and not have bombs going off and it is a
triggering thing seeing young um whether
again i bring it back to the whole point
i know we're looking at ukraine at the
moment but there are wars still going on
in syria there's things happening in
afghanistan and other places and
children around the world are scared and
i think that is something that we
shouldn't take for granted you mentioned
afghanistan and how much of a duty do
you think we have to afghanistan given
this country's role in the war there i
think we have i think we have a massive
duty i think we should be embarrassed in
the way that we've actually dealt with
things and for me again as a muslim
brown girl i was like you know the
inhumanity that the way that women are
being treated and we're completely
disregarding the
lives of afghani girls is actually
really really depressing yeah why do you
think we should be embarrassed
because the whole point is that we
actually just cut and run i think um i
think nate i think the big um kind of
countries have a role to play and this
idea the fact that we can reason and
legitimize the taliban who are people
actually you know men who hate women
it's actually quite wild in my um
thinking and i say that as somebody who
deals with men who are consistently
trying to roll back the rights that
women have um the taliban don't care
about women i think we should make that
clear and i think we should be doing and
we should be doing as much as we can in
order to be able to support a real
legitimate um like you know what's what
i'm looking for a legitimate alternative
to a taliban essentially when you say we
cut them around who do you mean by we i
mean
but i speak i i speak as a former child
refugee and as a feminism activist and
saying this but i think that both the uk
and the us were actually
like terrible in the way that they had
um that that they handled afghanistan i
just want to bring it to the uk because
i think it's interesting the point
you're making about race um
it's a very different issue but still in
a form of violence against women and
girls with what happened with child q
and this was the 15 year old girl who
was in the uk in london pulled out of an
exam and strip searched while on her
period by
the police while the teachers were
outside the room because she was
suspected of having cannabis which there
was no drugs on her
what's your reaction to that story i
mean i personally found it incredibly
shocking what was your reaction i know
it's an ongoing case and it's something
that is that should horrify us all and i
think the idea of a child being stripped
surged be they female or male should be
something that we shouldn't be able to
tolerate in this country and it said i
think in some of the reports afterwards
a safeguarding report said that racism
was likely to be a factor in that do you
know what it's it's sad that racism is
like this um i remember when the race
report came out and a lot of people
wanted me to kind of comment on that
like this country is one of the most
tolerant countries in europe but is
there more for us to do yes there is and
i think um kobe has actually really
brought out a lot of um kind of um cd
and unrest within people as well and
i've kind of experienced that in the
last two years that i like you know
really horrific
experience of racism which which i never
thought that the uk could be capable of
ultimately we have to talk about the
metropolitan police and institutional
racism are you talking about the police
there and the racism but also for sexism
and obviously the murder of sir by the
serving police officer really shone a
light on um sexism within the mets and i
just want to read some of the messages
that these were exchanged by officers at
tranquil police force they were exposed
by a report by the police watchdog last
month
i would have to rape you if i was single
i would happily chloroform you you ever
slap your missus it makes them love you
more seriously since i did that she
won't leave me alone
do you think there is a misogyny 100 i
think we have i think there's misogyny
like you know across this country at the
moment as well and there are things that
we're not talking about and ultimately i
think that again it's about the whole
conversation talking about prostitution
being seen as work when you're actually
paying for a woman's human rights and
liberty to be able to have sex with you
or not and access to porn there's
there's a lot of things that have
actually been that have gone um
unchecked and kind of corroded the way
that we have a social contract
and i said that on a day-to-day basis i
think the social contract between men
and women in this country is kind of
broken and we are completely living on
two different planets sometimes boris
johnson said this week the basic facts
of biology are important do you think
he's on the same side of the debate as
you are yeah i think any i think anybody
that understands basic biology
understands that which side we're on
when i'm not here to say that you know
that i don't believe that trans people
should have rights i fundamentally and
100 to you i've shared platforms way
before anybody else did with trans women
and i completely understand how the law
has to work when it thinks about fgm and
all these other kind of things these
conversations and i will fundamentally
support trans people but i don't think
that should actually take away the
rights that women are still fighting for
i guess others would argue that trans
women are also women and are also at
risk
but there but the reality is that trans
women are being murdered by men so
they're like like the people that are
killing trans women are the same people
that are killing women so we're on the
same side in terms of ending violence
against women and girls and i do think
and i do and i do support um the
protection of trans women but what i
don't support is this idea that the fact
that feminists like me and and and women
who are fighting for biological women or
issues that biological women are facing
are the enemy we are not the enemy their
enemies male violence and those things
have to change there are reports that
you were in a child care bubble
with the prime minister and his wife
over christmas 2020 and this of course
was at a time when london was under tier
three restrictions now at the time you
tweeted to say i've had two days of
racist and disgusting tweets because a
politics fraud a twitter account chose
to tag me in an untrue story no i did
not break any rules so this is your
chance to clear up what exactly
happened i think that's i think that
tweet said all um the fact that i didn't
break any rules and what was really
interesting was that the number of
people who understood that i didn't
break any rules that would um send me
private messages but not say anything
publicly with the kind of hateful things
i was getting so yeah so you were in a
childhood bubble which was allowed at
the time with the prime minister and
carrie is that like no rules or
brokenness that's one of the kind of
things and i think it's like the um and
the whole point is that's the main thing
that no rules were broken so but i think
we're kind of trivializing the fact that
we're talking about like you know
refugees were talking about trans rights
and everything else like that i think
something that was legal that happened
in 2020 should not necessarily be the
main bit of news today did you visit the
number 11 flat at any other time during
lockdown restrictions and have you been
contacted by the mec police and their
enquiries